welcome back to new rockstars the
mandalorian season 2
introduced live action ahsoka tano and
grand admiral thrawn
in a double whammy day felony homework
assignment to watch all of star wars
rebels by friday
don't worry while this could be
something explored on the mandalorian
i kind of feel like it is a too big a
conflict for a show about
the mandalorian and grogu and i think we
are looking at
an ahsoka thrawn spin-off i'm eric boss
this is rogue theory the show that
brings you
all the nerdy wildest hot takes on
topics we can't stop talking about which
right now
in the day of our lord uh december 2020
is the mandalorian uh with me to go
rogue today is
our friend the joven jedi jovan
glad to be back the setting stash
strikes again
strikes us against strikes so it strikes
back stress
strikes forever um also uh you can
find her streaming on twitch when she's
not gracing us with her presents
angelica trey hey
i'm glad to be back oh i'm doing good i
think we're all doing good what a time
to be alive with the mandalorian who
knew that we would be getting all this
crap in one
season eight episodes oh man not a drop
of filler maybe that ice spider episode
but not
not now and uh rounding out the panel
our buddy
welcome back tom michaelson always great
to have you man
thanks thanks i i got my honorary grogu
shirt and i'm gonna try to
i don't know why i've been saying gorgu
sometimes i'm gonna really try not to
i know it's not gorgu it's grogu so if i
say if i say gorgoo please
don't be mad just let me know in the
comments but please don't be mad
they'll yeah i'm sure they'll be very
polite in the comments
don't worry about it that's right uh
there's a gorgeous somewhere else we'll
meet
uh gorgu in in season 4.
you're not going to throw me out grogo
grogan
is going to cross over in thor foreign
and i don't have any help now
yeah yeah back to baby okay
let's dive into this uh chapter 13 the
mandalorian took amando
and grogu to the planet of corvus where
they meet ahsoka tano played by rosario
dawson
she is in the process of very much
pissing off morgan l smith
uh um we find out the apprentice to
surprise surprise grand admiral thrawn
the epic villain from star wars rebels
and before that
various expanded universe novels and i'm
gonna call it expanded universe because
it's not just legends to me it is an
expanded universe and that is thanks
to thrawn that guy is the heart of all
of it without thrawn we would not have
these amazing stories that inspired this
whole renaissance of animated series
uh you can tell that dave filoni clearly
loves these stories because they find
ways to put these into
the new movies in the shows and we love
that uh and
thrawn though more recently is important
to us because he was such a big villain
in star wars rebels
he disappeared alongside ezra bridger
and that is who
ahsoka and sabine were looking for in
that final epilogue scene
of star wars rebels so to find thrawn
means to find
ezra but she seems kind of pissed off at
him there is a deeper anger there and
i've made a couple theories
about who thrawn is what his plan might
be and uh as well as ahsoka's full
timeline because she's been on like
everything now
uh and that includes dave filoni's
recent update that the rebels finale
epilogue scene might actually take place
after ahsoka's current arc on the
mandalorian
possibly he says check out those videos
here
i have these three experts that are
gonna help me with this
the reason these two heavyweights are
being brought onto live action
i think is to give a big path forward to
the future of the whole star wars
universe i really do think we could be
looking at a spin-off
so uh without further ado i want to hear
from you three
pitch me what you think this ahsoka
thrawn spin-off
could look like jovan why don't you go
first
oh i am ready to talk your ear about
this uh but this rogue theory i've got
it's not gonna leave a smile on your
face uh as as
accurate as it will wind up being it'll
it'll it'll get you
feeling in the feels because outside of
the mandalorian being the first star
wars
series that we have here we're there's
talks of other disney plus spin-off
shows an ob1 series uh now maybe an
ahsoka tano series
and from what we've heard so far is that
they might just be like you know one
season telestory kind of thing and i
think that's what we'll get
from ahsoka tano spin-off where
it is her trying to find and stop
thrawn but what is thrawn doing well
because it's the star wars universe
everything is connected and
thrawn is in fact connected to the plot
of star wars episode nine
by being that emperor palpatine has
a few different eggs with baskets he
doesn't have everything just kind of
like falling on
on snoke to kind of get the the first
order up and running
if that doesn't work out he doesn't have
to work out he also has thrawn
there you know taking out all these
different planets to get resources to
create
a fleet to create its own uh
maybe fleet of the sith just in case of
all the other plans don't work out it's
just another
puppet in the grand scheme of palpatine
and i think that ahsoka tano's
story is going to be about finding
thrawn and stopping this from happening
because we do hear her voice at the end
of rise of skywalker
implying that you know she's no longer
with us and that's where the feels start
to come in
we've seen this great story arc from
ahsoka
from from you know just the padawan
to going out on her own and then seeing
her as like a ronin samurai if you will
and she
if you read the book she's like hesitant
to help people she doesn't really know
where she fits in she doesn't know who
can she who she can trust
and i think this is where we see her arc
where she finds her meaning to her life
and what she needs to do
she has seen what an what a galactic
empire can do
what a giant fleet what a giant army can
do to the universe
so she's going to do everything in her
power to stop thrawn from doing it again
and i think that uh it will cost her her
life to stop thrawn
but and unfortunate for her palpatine
has you know
those other eggs and baskets and then
that's why we see the new order in snoke
kind of rise up with kylo ren on the
side
because you know he he's got plan b's
and c's
yeah this guy is the ultimate
contingency planner uh in
every new uh corner operation
f yes
that's something different but it's also
canon i have um
i either want to destroy the galaxy or
also rebuild it at the same time i'm a
confusing catholic
yes also he has kids uh and grandkids
that guy why choose a
vocation you can have it all and
palpatine's a proof in the puddin
um hey what you uh dig into there
jovin with your theory is like uh truth
about ahsoka
that she cannot be confined to just a
subplot of the mandalorian
and i'm so glad you brought up her book
because
as i i don't think the way forward for
her character is for
dave filoni to just say uh her stories
in star wars rebels and clone wars just
go watch those
no those are going to they're going to
exist and they're going to be great for
people to go back and look at
but they're going to do more with
rosario dawson and there is more
depth to her character that you can
really only truly connect audiences with
by
having them in live action i'm sorry i
love ashley eckstein but rosario dawson
is going to be the way forward for this
character
when it is the highest rated episode of
mandalorian to date
and there's no way disney plus doesn't
see that as a big old money sign oh
it's gonna happen um uh so i'm going to
award you
two points joven i would give you more
but i just have like slightly different
feelings
on whether thrawn is a piece in
palpatine's puzzle
i couldn't see anytime you tie something
to episode nine it's gonna rub a few
people that way
i just want to be his own thing i want
thrawn to be
a kind of an enemy to that whole thing
just so they can be like yes that
happened but now we have thrawn and you
have thrawn and we all have thrown it's
gonna be great
um but great theory joven uh two points
two points to drove indoors
yes um all right angelica it is your
turn how do you think i
uh thrawn ahsokatano spin-off could look
okay
so this is good news for you then on
your thrawn
hopes and theories because i'm thinking
ahsoka
will go on a revenge mission of like a
cat and mouse
chasing thrawn in hopes of finding ezra
bridger
okay since thrawn is known as one of the
you know most genius like military
strategist in the empire i definitely
think he's going to be a moriarty style
character that's always going to be one
step ahead of ahsoka's great badassery
yeah
i love moriarty and i love like i know
it's completely different franchise but
i think he's gonna be such a good
character for it
and if i recall correctly the voice
actor
in who played was it thrawn
at one point in the animated series was
a character or like a villain from
sherlock so there's some ties here
oh lars mickelson was he yeah yeah yeah
lars
i'm thinking that in this spin-off we're
going to have that moriarty style
throng here too character who's one step
ahead
and then along the way while ahsoka's on
her journey she runs into
you know sabine and sabine joins that
mission because sabine wants to find
ezra as well
and even though all signs point to ezra
maybe being dead or like they just
haven't heard anything
they will actually find ezra
on maybe like a random planet laying low
because he got
separated from thrawn after that space
wheel jump what are they called the
the pearl pearls yeah pergal
that are purging um so
they're gonna find ezra it's gonna be
epic it's gonna be the best best scene
ever
and ezra's gonna be like i'm actually
tracking thrawn
and they're gonna find out that thrawn
is trying to build his
own empire and that he's gotta be
stopped before
you know more casualties more innocence
die
uh yeah what i like about your pitch
there
angelica is the fact that like halfway
through
it sounds like ahsoka meets sabine so
correct me if i'm wrong are you saying
that
uh you're going with uh you're leaning
on the more possible than less possible
side of felony's interpretation that
final scene
that maybe it was after the current arc
of mandalorian we're gonna follow her
on her own for a bit more and then catch
up to her when she
uh runs into sabine on lothal uh
and they're like all right girl let's go
i know absolutely
yeah we're gonna be like finding friends
along the way but i still
love ahsoka tano as
that you know kind of similar to mando
but like that lone
ranger type character and then we'll
find that journey
of of her reconnecting along the way
yeah
i like that too um and what i hope this
ends up being i don't know if i need
another six seasons in a movie of ahsoka
tano
but like disney plus seems okay with
limited run
miniseries uh in the same way that uh
the clone wars final season
was a short run that they knew would
have a finite ending
uh it was 12 episodes that was really
four episodes four episodes and four
episodes right you had the clone trooper
arc
you had the martez sister arc and then
you had the
siege of mandalore arc order 66 arc and
that those four episodes were some of
the whole world
best moment like together that was like
my favorite star wars movie in a way
so uh if they could just do that with
ahsoka just like we're doing five
episodes of ahsoka just to show you
how she does that like that could be the
perfect way to do it because that way it
wouldn't completely erase everything
ashley eckstein did
because there is so much there you know
um
great yeah i think you and i are very
much in agreement angelica
uh so i'm uh just out of bias because i
can't be an impartial judge
i'm gonna give you three three points uh
three points to angelica dork
i'll take them thank you three points
then
three points it is um all right tom it
is your turn uh tell us
your vision for this a thrawn ahsoka
spinoff
so i i think this works because it takes
a little bit of what each of you guys
have said
um kind of like what eric started with
how theology was saying maybe
that scene at the end of rebels wasn't
um exactly after the end of rebels so i
think that
the new ahsoka show will start with her
finding sabine in that moment
um to help her find thrawn uh and sabine
of course will come along because she
wants to find ezra
but their mission will get interrupted
by a new mystery
where children from all over the galaxy
have gone missing
and ahsoka's afraid that palpatine's old
plan from the clone wars where he
kidnapped force sensitive children is
back
and unfortunately to make matters worse
one of the first children to go missing
is jason syndulla uh that which is the
kids
hera and kanan's son um so hara is going
to
enlist uh ahsoka's help it's a beans
help of course uncle zeb's gonna come
along for the ride
and they're gonna go have to find out
what's happening with these uh missing
children live action sam
a live action live action zebra coming
to this show
is what i want to see but um but as this
ragtag group goes along and tries to
help
figure out this mystery we're gonna find
out that
uh who's actually kidnapping the
children is thrawn
so their missions are actually
coalescing and that thrawn is kidnapping
these children because
he's wanting to build an army of his own
which
at this point of time is the first order
that's right i'm calling i think thrawn
is the one
who actually started and built up the
first order
and that and then later down the line
maybe palpatine will take it over and
make it his own but
but uh you know there's actually preston
for this too because like finn if finn
really is a force sensitive
i was just about to say yeah this this
ties in it's not only him but like jaina
or janna the other girl from
episode nine that's right you know
there's there's already a present for uh
for force sensitive kids in
as stormtroopers and and we know from
the books that thrawn
um you know actually uses force
sensitive kids to
be there his map wayfinders i think
skywalkers
but um but yeah i think that uh that
this is uh thrawn's play to create his
own empire that he calls
the first order but palpatine comes in
and takes that over later we can worry
about that and try to make those movies
make sense but
for now for now this is thrawn's this is
uh the thrawn's mission is to take these
four sensitive kids
and create the first order wow wow tom
that's a that's a really
hot take i love that idea of uh of
because we know certain things about the
origin of the first order from the
aftermath books right uh
you had uh grand admiral ray sloane you
had
uh brendol hux um but there's still a
lot of
about that uh yeah there's um it's in
the unknown regions which we know thrawn
knows very very well
but here's what i love about your theory
you took elements from rebels
and from clone wars this whole plot um
correct me if i'm wrong are you talking
about the
whole cad bane thing of stealing the
jedi archives holocron of all the four
sensitive kids
around the galaxy yeah that's a cool
plotline and i would love for that to
come back that there is some kind of you
know because a jedi were kind of a cult
they would have that list
uh and for that to be weaponized in a
way uh
like it again leaks because the jedi
archives they burned you know they they
that would have been sacked that would
have been something you'd have to worry
about getting out there that is
essentially what the whole inquisitors
thing grew out of of
the dark side or the the empire
gathering whoever the survivor
surviving jedi were pulling them over
the dark side and turning them into
hunters into blade runners i guess
essentially
um but yeah yeah the using that cool
leftover thing from the animated series
to fix
something we weren't crazy about um not
just the confusion over how the first
order came about
but that missed opportunity within that
clearly he had some kind of force
sensitivity if he could wield
the lightsaber as well as he did and
they kind of hinted at the end where he
sensed you know uh he sensed that
that death in the rise of skywalker but
clearly john boyega was like
you [ __ ] had an opportunity
so this could be a way you bring him
back in there maybe or you know maybe
have a younger actor play him or
something
yeah uh i love so much about your theory
um i am going to give it
uh just because i'm still nervous i
don't know if the first order needs to
be tied directly to thrawn i have this
this fear that if you tie it too much in
episode night so that's that's my bias
that's my personal bias but i'm still
going to give you three points for
yourself
i'll take it i'll take it i i think it
does bring up an interesting point cause
all of these ideas sound like that
they could happen um especially mine uh
but
if we get ahsoka spin-off like how is it
just not
rebel season five in live action right
right
yeah they and or how is it not um you
know rise of skywalker or the
for force awakens prequel you know
like i you want it to be its own
distinct thing
and you also want it to fix some of the
problems
so it's kind of like a question of
priorities right do we want to explore
ahsoka's character and thrawn's
character uh
or do we want something that kind of
what the clone wars was to attack of the
clones and the other prequels that it
kind of
righted some of the wrongs with context
with other characters and he told the
true story
of the prequels um gave you that kind of
certain point of view
angle yeah and i think that it's really
interesting because up until this point
of season two and mandalorian
i think we're all fine with having a
separate thing that's just
which is great all of a sudden we had
that episode where they're like that's a
tank of clones they're they trying to
say something about snoke
and then we have ahsoka come out we're
like okay now we're really tying and
then she says thrawn
now it's like okay anything can happen
we'll just blow the doors off of star
wars exactly
who knows planting all the seeds all the
seeds exactly all the eggs and every bat
like drone was saying everything's
happening now and everything's on the
table so yeah who knows
yeah i think um well here's what we all
know coming out of the mandalorian right
is that dave filoni
definitely deserves to be the chief kind
of creative officer of the star wars
universe going on
george lucas he deserves to be george
lucas he deserves to be what george
likes
what he said makes sense too yeah yeah
george lucas
he needs to be the kevin feige of that
even though they do have kevin feige
making star wars movies just put felony
in charge please that guy
gets it uh and he knows how to deliver
these beautiful cinematic moments um
but the way the what he did so well with
clone wars and with rebels is
he didn't try to fix every problem he
just gave you certain characters and
told their stories
and by telling ahsoka story you were
able to tell anakin's story in a way
that the prequel movies did not
because it gave us a new kind of a
heartstring to tug at of
why anakin was able to do what he did
why he turned to the dark side well part
of it was
one of his best friends was betrayed by
the jedi order and that
planted the seed of mistrust in him and
that kind of gave you more perspective
and it helped us process and go back
re-watch protect the clones and revenge
of sith and feel a lot better about them
even the revenge of the set i think was
always freaking great
um but we're going to keep talking about
the mandalorian we have
more things we want to talk about before
we continue we want to thank some
friends who helped us make this episode
first story our friends at expressvpn it
is
december and that means it is time for
christmas movies
but what if you go to netflix and you
discover your favorite christmas movie
isn't available based off of where you
live get ready to have your mind blown
you can use expressvpn to watch any
netflix library
in the world i'm talking
die hard on south korean netflix or elf
on australia netflix all from the
comfort of your home
that's not in south korea or australia
if you live somewhere else you get to
get them
it's simple you just open the app you
hit one button you change your location
you refresh netflix and that is it
expressvpn lets you control where you
want sites to think you're located you
can choose from almost
100 countries that's a lot of netflix
libraries
xrs vpn also works with other streaming
services disney plus hulu
bbc iplayer you name it there are
hundreds of vpns out there but the
reason i use
expressvpn to watch movies and shows is
because it is ridiculously
fast there's never any buffering you can
always stream in hd
expressvpn works with all your devices
too phones tablets smart tvs whatever
use it to watch whatever you want on the
go or on the big screen
if you visit my special link right now
expressvpn.com
rogue you can get an extra three months
of expressvpn for
free support the show watch what you
want and get your holiday fix
at expressvpn.com rogue okay we also
want to thank our friends at manscaped
brace yourselves winter is coming now we
all miss game of thrones and all the
glorious beards on that show
those hairy hairy northerners could have
really used our wonderful sponsor
manscaped not only could it have helped
them stay looking good
all over manscape's lawnmower 3.0
trimmer
could have helped prevent nicks and cuts
westeros has seen enough bloodshed
already
the new lawnmower 3.0 is waterproof with
advanced
skin safe technology and even has a
light
to help you shave everywhere because the
night is dark and full of terrors but
your under regions don't have to be uh
they also have got the
weed whacker ear and nose hair trimmer
to make sure your facial hair doesn't
trespass the
north of the lip wall oh yeah that's
what that's what i need
that's what i need a lot everyone's like
why is vos reacting to these uh talking
points in real time well i am kind of
being ron burgundy right now
um you have smelly feet well manscaped
can help with their foot duster foot
deodorant made to fight odor on real
funky feet like
sandra clegane level funk wanna smell
good everywhere
while the refined cologne by manscaped
is a clean and fresh scent designed for
the refined gentlemen
get twenty percent favorite one it
really is wild you can get
20 off and free shipping with the code
rogue theory at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use the code rogue theory be sure to
join
the manscaped movement these products
are
snow joke
i literally read it in good views and as
i said it it became clear
puns do that to you
uh all right let's get back to the
mandalorian we are now
in the second half of the season i guess
technically 5 8 of the way through
and we are starting to build up usually
these last three episodes build up
toward the finale episode
now last season's final shots gave us
moff gideon emerging from
his ship wreckage wielding the freaking
darksaber
uh that was a huge moment i have a
feeling
the finale of this season is gonna do
a similar thing to us star wars loves to
do that and felony loves to do that
so i want to hear from you guys what do
you think that final shot's gonna be
what is the final scene of season two of
the mandalorian
going to reveal to us all right so as
you were saying like you know star wars
loves cliffhangers and
this being season two i think this is
going to be their chance to do like an
empire strikes back where
it ends with a big like what the hell do
we do now moment
so just sitting there setting the scene
so they get to uh to tithe on
dan places grogu on the seeing stone
just as moff gideon is arriving because
he placed the tracker on a ship
that's right tomorrow um didn't see
gideon and tries to buy him some time
uh by taking him on using the spear and
there's gonna be a dark saber spear
fight
um and he barely gets the upper hand and
is about to defeat them off
when we hear a tracking fob sound now
this is rogue theory so i'm gonna go
real rogue here i think he's going wrong
i'm going around i think that din's
gonna be very exhausted at the fight
he's gonna turn around and see
cad bane cad bain is gonna be coming out
with his tracking fob
because he's still tracking now there's
still a bounty on the kid from season
one
um gideon knowing knowing that he's a
bad hunter is going to be like
you know i'll give you double if you
kill him right now he shoots uh he'll
shoot
mando in the head and the best guard
will knock him out he'll go up for the
killing blow
and then then we start hearing spurs the
spurs that we know
know who it is boba fett shows up
because he's tracking
he's been tracking them on his own to
find his own armor
so then boba shows up and uh he sees
bain and this will be the first time
they've seen each other since clone wars
and we'll get kind of an answer on
whether or not that there's a famous
deleted scene from clone wars where
cad bane and boba fett actually had a
duel and cad bain is the one who gave uh
boba the dent in his helmet
there's a deleted scene and and and you
can watch animatics on youtube right now
but it's unclear whether that's canon or
not but we'll get an answer to that
um they'll they'll have a fight they'll
have an all-out brawl and just as cad
bane's about to lose
um you know gideon will stop him and be
like hey boba i know you're a bounty
hunter
don't kill him why don't you help me
i'll offer you a bounty to stop jaren
and help me
uh kidnap grogu bobo would be like
i don't need money i'm just here to get
my armor like i don't care about that
and then he goes no i'm not trying to
give you money
i'll tell you the location of han solo
luke skywalker
and leia organa right now if you help me
whoa we'll turn to dan and be like
sorry he'll uh he'll and then then
this will end this will be the final
scene so um
uh we boba is flying off in the ridge
crest now he has his armor he steals
mando's ship
um cad bain and moth gideon take grogu
they they fly off in his ship
and we reveal that din is not only still
knocked out defeated
but they've stripped them of his armor
and his weapons his
his favorite helmet is now gone and he's
laying there
kind of lifeless boom fade to black
whoa if it's gonna be empire we gotta go
hard
this is gonna be terrifying this has to
be it's gonna be something crazy
what you oh man tom like i know like
star wars timeline i feel like pretty
well but
when you said those three's name i'm
like [ __ ] yeah they're all
alive right now they're all on chandrila
or wherever you know just hanging out
so that is freaking terrifying if that's
where it is
they're gonna save the jedi stuff for
ahsoka like now that we know uh-huh
is coming i don't know if we're gonna
have someone show up a jedi i mean
with groga at the end they might who
knows but this is a show about bounty
hunters so
if we're gonna have batteries we need to
bring out the big guns at the end here
and to bring in cad bane it kind of ties
in with your earlier theory of uh
of that whole leftover player ties into
his first theory he had tied up with
their first series
what an amazing theory if it ends that
it's one of those theories where it's
like well damn if they don't do that i'm
gonna be a little bumped
right uh it's hard to get so invested in
those ideas yeah
i'm gonna give you a solid four points
that was a good theory
uh okay um now to you other two you do
not have to go you don't have to feel
too much competition i want you to
stick with your vision of this it can be
whatever you think it is
and just be true to yourselves uh
angelica it is your turn
what do you think the final image of the
season season's gonna be
okay so i definitely think that we're
going to
end the season with the seeing stone
and amanda's going to be setting grogu
on the stone and gideon's gonna arrive
we know like gideon's just lurking in
the shadows he's gonna pop back in i
just
i feel it's in my in my bones um
so i think mando's going to get into an
epic you know
saber spear fight right now he has this
fear
um with gideon and he's almost going to
lose but then
grogu is going to sense mando's near
demise
and he's going to use the force to harm
and like blast gideon away or something
like he's gonna
we're gonna see a little dark grosgu
we're gonna see grogue's dark side
oh cool uh-huh because we're gonna tie
it back too
but it's gonna be so adorable oh it's
gonna be so cute
but we're gonna we're gonna be heeding
ahsoka's
you know words from earlier in the
season
right where ahsoka tano warned
mando of grogu's dangerous attachment to
him
and so we're going to see that start to
play out at the end of this season
and so you know um
so then gideon's just off somewhere you
know he's he's off screen he's going to
come back later or something
and a jedi is going to show up and
answer the call
and mando's going to essentially
surrender
grogu because he doesn't want grogu to
go
to the dark side and turn you know evil
and the uh jedi's going to leave with
grogu and go and train him and mando's
gonna be once again alone it's gonna be
it's gonna be a very melancholic ending
but we know that mando's going to look
out for grogu to the end
yeah oh i also really like that theory
angelica i
um i think we all kind of know it's a
given that we're gonna see
a duel between moth gideon and in
jarring this season but the idea of
baby yoda going dark i feel like that's
kind of been what this season it's been
setting up
right like he he's eaten those uh
unfertilized frog eggs like they're
nothing uh and
that's four stroke from season one yeah
there's a fourth stroke from season one
and now there's this renewed concern
that he could follow in the steps of
anakin skywalker so
yeah i i think that would be a really
cool way to end the season of uh
got it yeah the bad one the chosen
um all right angelica i'm gonna give you
three points for your theory
i i like that take thank you all right
i gotta get a little tactical here i'm
gonna get it
right here we got some good ones
like these are great dark side baby yoda
uh connection to the original trilogy
characters how do you compete with that
well i don't have to play smart here so
here's what i think is going to happen
in the final episode and to back it up a
little bit end of episode seven
we will actually that'll be the moment
where uh grogu gets put onto the seeing
stone
uh and then it's like all right i hope
someone finds them i guess
and that is you know as uh moff gideon
is now on planet uh
we're at the height of the you know the
the climax here what happens in the
final episode well
uh i do think that fight is going to
happen there's the reason why he's got
the best scar spear the reason it's a
spear is because
um the actor obviously already has his
his
bo staff skills his his spear skills
already honed because of game of thrones
so we're gonna see that dark saber slash
best car spear fight
and it's gonna be great but you know he
hasn't had a lot of time to practice
with the spear
he's going to get uh disarmed because
that's what we like to do here in in
star wars people are gonna be losing
some weapons
and as mafidion goes to throat the final
strike
with his dark saber on on din
a blue lightsaber shows up
hits the dark side away flies back hits
right into someone's hand as we pan up
and there is cal kestis
ready to save the day he was the one
that made the that caught the call
from from grogu because dave palone has
connected
novels he's collect he's connected to
comics he's connected to holiday
specials
they have yet to connect to the canon
video game series
and this is our chance to bring calcus
to the live action
world where he's there to save the day
so we remember at the end of uh jedi
fallen order
they had this this holocron of of jedi
children
that i believe that they destroyed but
they know that there are children out
there
and other people need to be saved it's
been quite a few years since that
incident
uh and this is this is their cruise plan
is to find these these children and kind
of
save them from the dark path that that's
been laid uh
upon them after episode three so it sets
in motion this this
cow meets din uh with with grogu there
it's like what is the future of grogu
what is the future of of grand uh of uh
gideon's
gideon grandma gideon yeah his plans uh
but now connected to the video game
universe
so that i think is what we're gonna see
and why else
get like uh like when they got calcus
uh when they got uh monahan to do his
face that was just enough time for him
to kind of age
right into this so yeah it all works out
timing wise
they've been planning this for a while
guys we're connected with the video
games
hell yeah dude that does make a ton of
sense
and yeah uh we do have some logistical
problems having mark hamill come back
right
he's he's an older fella still looks
pretty good but we've seen him as
old luke skywalker we did see that brief
moment where they d aged him and rise of
skywalker but it did look you know they
just had a solo light source of his
lightsaber i
it would be kind of weird looking and i
don't think they would want them
they'd have to be very careful they'd
have to put a lot of hood work maybe get
someone else playing him
uh it'd be tough it'd be tough because
they pulled that out with carrie fisher
uh but calcus is a bit more mystery a
bit and game
uh players would know who that is but
they could set that up of just like
saying his name
like uh mandalorian what you do at the
end of every mandalorian episode where
everyone's like wait
who's this guy goes to google finds new
rock stars
five things you didn't know about
calgary
it's just what they do
well and a character that not everyone
has their minds made up about uh yet you
know
so with maul they pulled that move when
solo right where they brought in maul
people had opinions about but
they thought he was dead and they're
like wait he's actually alive again
they're like yeah go watch
the clone wars but uh yeah with this
it's going to be i could imagine that
same kind of thing of like a kind of
relatively fresh face
that uh a jedi who is still out there
you know
uh there's a you can count them on one
hand but calcus is one of them i'm going
to give you four points for that
yeah that was good that was good
you're still in this your tactical uh
strategy
paid off all right so we have a
relatively even score we got tom with
seven and we got joe
angelico with six points but all can be
changed with our final round of rogue
questions our first question the
national research group
released a list of the top fan favorite
franchises over the last two years this
week
so the list had 10 marvel properties in
the top 20. mandalorian was number one
stranger things in the witcher also got
in the list
i want you guys to pitch me on what
completely unexpected franchise
could crack the top 20 two years from
now
i'm going i'm i'm going with what i know
i know video games
uh we're getting some uh like a mario
animated film right can someone confirm
that yes
well we're gonna get one it's my rogue
theory that we're getting a mario
brothers
uh uh animated movie which will then
lead into like a nintendo
uh cinematic universe and eventually
we'll have a smash brothers movie
and that's gonna be the top of the
charts baby yeah
yeah i first say box but then i'm like
well duh yeah of course
of course that's actually gonna happen
we're getting nintendo uh universal
studios japan so it only makes sense
that they start to follow up with
movies duh i'm also thinking
of last of us because that too is
spanning from the game world
over to television now they're making a
series for it
craig mason is producing that yeah the
games are
so good yeah the games are amazing and
it's a whole new take at least
for me having seen so much zombie stuff
out there it's a whole new take on like
that
zombie-esque you know franchise it's the
it's the the fungi zombies
so i think that would be really cool and
i i think that it's going to be
looked back on especially the game last
of us part two and it's going to be
really highly regarded yeah it's going
to be the new walking dead
yeah and because i mean obviously
walking dead was great
uh i believe it has peaked frank derebot
did amazing stuff in that first season
uh they were able to keep it going for a
couple good seasons after that
i think it has been trash for two years
at least
uh but the guy the team behind this last
of us
hbo adaptation uh craig mason is a guy i
briefly met
at austin film festival a couple years
ago he did chernobyl for hbo he made
uh chernobyl as something that
took over uh all social media that
summer um
so he's an amazing screenwriter so
that's going to be great and he's
paired up with the actual writer from
the game and the writer from the game so
yeah it's gonna be amazing
so good yeah all right tom what do you
think
so i don't know how many uh people in
our audience uh watch this but i'm gonna
go with the last show i watched which i
really liked
queen's gambit except that in every
season instead of just playing chess
she's gonna be playing
all these other games she's gonna be
doing like you know uh she will be like
guess who she's gonna be doing checkers
she's gonna do a season maybe she's been
going to gaming she'll do like call of
duty and start crushing
everybody yeah she'll be a new twitch
streamer she'll just crush
every game and every genre um until the
end of time and that'll be one of the
biggest series oh yeah
yeah hopefully she could totally even
like skee-ball when things open up she's
gonna be out in the arcades
basketball she'll crush i bet you she'd
crash basketball
all of these things she has like her
mind vision playing it on the ceiling
when she looks
right right right yeah i love that um
i'm gonna give the point just because i
think this is the most accurate i think
jovin's right on the money i think we're
gonna see a nintendo cinematic
yeah it only makes too much sense a
welcome surprise for sure
yeah all right so final question in the
last two weeks mysterious metal
monoliths i'm sure you've seen this
straight out of 2001 a space odyssey
have appeared in the utah desert and
then
outside of romanian village no one
currently as of the station is taking
responsibility for their appearance
it is time to confess you three admit
why you have been the one
placing metal monoliths around the world
and the police are coming
outside
i'll confess first first of all guys
just want to say i'm sorry i
um i but there's a good reason why i was
doing it so
you know everybody's really hyped about
these metal models they like they like
how they look they like the mystery
behind it and i've just been putting
them everywhere and i'm going to put
some more out just to build some more
hype so that way when
the pandemic is over everyone's going to
be rushing to take a look at these and
there'll be no lines
anywhere else like i'm going to go to
cheesecake factory and sit down
instantly
i'm going to go to six flags ride roller
coasters multiple times
and and yeah and i'm going to go to
disneyland using that will be super easy
because every
everyone will be just worried about
these model lists and checking that out
so sorry guys sorry my evil plan finally
come into play
let me tell you two structures down
three to go
once i have all five monoliths placed in
the five corners of the globe that's
right a globe has five corners
and the planets align it shall open up
the board up to the multiverse and i
shall conquer
every single parallel universe this
world has ever seen
oh my god
all right get hydrated so
all right i must confess i'm putting up
these monoliths because
they're made out of this special
material i'm trying to signal the aliens
to come over here
help us out maybe guide us out of this
situation that is this year
and it's essentially a sign for them i'm
it's a beacon all right calling to the
aliens come help us
also i kind of want like a starfleet
situation to unfold
or you can just help yeah help us out
maybe yeah
put us in the uh what is it
intergalactic uh
space society i think we're ready i
think we're ready i think we're ready to
i think we're ready but we we're kind of
like the grease of the european union
it's like yes
we'd love to be in this club but really
like bail us out please
yes grease ii of the galactic senate
we right now in the year 2020 we might
be the planet that they go you know what
i don't know if i want to vacation at
that one
i think we might just skip tours
yeah we'll come back next year um well
i'm going to give the point to joven for
this one which i think
puts you over the top you came from
behind to come that kid
over and uh i have to say you guys gave
me goosebumps with all of your answers
all of the theories this episode this is
one of the episodes where every
all six pitches are something where it's
like i want to see that
at some point i look forward to our
rebels animation style
uh spin-off series where we see you know
the original ot
gang get together and have to like beat
boba fett yeah
hell yeah uh well uh a
wonderful episode of rogue theory i want
to thank all three of our guests uh
jovin our winner today uh as well as
angelica tray
and tom michelson follow all three of
them on
everywhere that you can follow them
except in real life that's weird don't
do that but
yeah you can find me at ea
and you can follow me in real life if
you can find me
i don't know where i am so how will you
um
don't forget to subscribe to rogue
theory the podcast feed wherever you get
your podcast leave us a nice radium
review
uh follow new rockstars on socials check
out our merch store
new rockstarsmerch.com we got lots of
great options including a new grogu
shirt that's hot off the presses
and uh we got a wanda vision shirt
coming out as well soon with
gonna have a ton of great easter eggs in
there that you can find everyone stay
safe out there
see you next time bye everybody
[Music]
you